good morning st. Louis this is a early
wake-up call from garry kasparov at the
opening ceremony you'll move I stood in
the playing hall talking with Gary and
what unfolded before us was a game by
five time world champion this one athan
anon with white against the number three
rated player in the world fabiano
caruana and Fabio played the Berlin
defense which of course is very well
known to Gary here we watched the game
closely after the movie 3 video see [ __ ]
and then night BD to buy fishy fishy
wants to capture the night and capture
the pumpkin Fabio he ignored the threat
he'd said go ahead and take it and
that's exactly what she did captured the
ball so as I'm talking to Gary in the
White Hall i said i don't get it i don't
see the compensation for black for
family for rookie a night at 3d 5v5 and
i said this looks great to me I think
blacks in real trouble
Gary says I'm not so sure I say why not
because I will play Knight g4 attacking
the pawn on e5 attacking the pond or f2
I said well that's terrible Gary I'll
play d4 attacking the bishop protecting
the pond gaining a tempo playing h three
blacks busted he says not so fast yessir
this is Gary's trick and boy did he
trick me well Gary took my pawn I said
what's that I'll take your Bishop he's
had green age 4 i'm going to give you
checkmate here or you can castle i'll
check mate you on h2 exit I don't get it
i'll play g3 Gary says well not i'll
play Knight takes a vine oh my goodness
and what's this the threat is Queen
takes d4 if you take the Queen which I
did Gary says check maven2 yessir 9 a-3
check king f1 bishop h3 check and mate
the rook covers the e-file there's no
squares for the king well that was my
wake-up call and that was what i wanted
to share with st. Louis I hope you
enjoyed that because I sure didn't
you